[Musique]
kel
installez-vous et notre invité ce matin
c'est Gill kpel bonjour monsieur kpel
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous vous
êtes politologue spécialiste du monde
arabe et on regarde votre dernier livre
prophète en son pays c'est aux éditions
de l'Observatoire c'est un livre plutôt
personnel vous décryptez la la montée de
l'islamisme on va en parler mais d'abord
évidemment on va parler de ce qui se
passe et de ce conflit entre Israël et
le Hamas jusqu'à quand Benjamin
netaniaou peut-il continuer son
offensive et refuser le CC de feu
sachant que le nombre de civiles tué à
Gaza dépasse les 8000 ben la position de
Benjamin netaniaahou est très difficile
en Israël même puisqu'il est considéré
par beaucoup d'Israéliens comme le
responsable de la catastrophe qui s'est
abattu sur l'État hébreu en dégarnissant
la frontière avec Gaza en faisant que
l'armée israélienne était occupée a des
opérations de police pour satisfaire ses
alliés de l'extrême droite procolon en
sisjordanie lesquels au Parlement lui
Assur la cessette lui assurait la
majorité lui permettant de ne pas aller
en justice pour rendre compte des chefs
d'inculpation qui se sont multipliés
contre lui et d'autre part pour changer
la constitution ce qui fait que pour la
première fois dans l'histoire sans doute
l'État d'Israël à l'intérieur duquel il
y a toujours des débats extrêmement
violents à l'Assemblée ça rien à voir
avec le le calme que vous connaissez au
Sénat ici à Paris euh avait toujours
conservé au moment de du danger une
espèce de sentiment de de de fusion
mobilisation générale si vous voulez ce
qui n'a pas été le cas là les les
pilotes par exemple qui ont les lit de
l'armée refusaient de faire leurs
entraînements pour pour protester contre
ça moi je donc il a une part de
responsabilité énorme j'ai suivi ça dans
la presse arabe à travers ce qu'écrivait
le Hezbollah ce qui se trouvent sur les
réseaux sociaux du Hamas ils n'avaient
jamais vu ça ils étaient ils attendaient
le moment où il pourraent profiter de ça
pour attaquer et ça s'est produit et
donc aujourd'hui la principale
difficulté pour dans la dans la logique
israélienne he si on veut rentrer dans
leur tête c'est que l'offensive est est
dirigée en le Premier ministre par
celui-là même qui a emmené le pays au
désastre donc tant que les Israéliens
n'ont pas trouvé une solution euh pour
cela ils vont se trouver dans une
position extrêmement difficile à
l'international je crois en terme
d'image comment faire en sorte que
l'individu netanahou soit aujourd'hui
celui qui décide de l'offensive même si
derrière il y a les généraux et autres
alors pour ce qui est de l'offensive
elle-même comme vous avez vu c'est une
offensive qui contrairement à ce qui
avait été annoncé n'est pas un blitz
Toal qui est une inentive graduée et qui
en fait s'effectue dans un contexte
international où en réalité les voies de
la négociation sont en permanence et
discrètement en fonction en particulier
à partir du Qatar pour pourquoi elle est
graduée est-ce que justement parce qu'il
y a une pression de la communauté
internationale ou est-ce que la question
des otages joue aussi beaucoup les deux
les deux puisque vous avez vu que le
Qatar s'engage à obtenir la négociation
la libération de certains otage alors
par exemple Poutine est en train de
pourire ses propres intérêts euh de
négocier la négociation de négocier la
libération pardon de russseau euh
israéliens euh la France va peut-être
obtenir aussi des
francoisraéliens et cetera les
Américains font sortir des gens de Gaza
donc si vous voulez euh c'est une il y a
une guerre qui se produit sur le terrain
qui est atroce euh qui d'une certaine
manière établit la balance dans dans
l'horreur avec le massacre qui a eu lieu
euh le 7 octobre avec les 1400 civils
israéliens qui ont été tirés comme des
lapins d'une certaine manière dans une
sorte de jeu de massacre
particulièrement atroce et encore en en
Europe on a vu quand on a euh quand on
est àé qu'on regarde que la télévision
on a vu que les images flouté mais les
scènes qui circulent sur les réseaux
sociaux à travers le monde pour les ados
et autres sont absolument atroces et
évidemment donne des idées à un certain
nombre d'individus mais euh on voit
moins les euh
les conséquences des bombardements en à
Gaza aujourd'hui mais bien évidemment
quand des enfants meurent sous les
bombes quand des familles sont décimées
et cetera ou
liquidé l'intensité dans l'horreur si
vous voulez est équivalente le problème
dans ce conflit comme dans beaucoup
d'autres c'est que d'une certaine
manière chacun s'intéresse à ses propres
mort et ce qui est légitime mais pour
pour nous qui sommes en France c'est qui
observons ce phénomène la France est un
pays qui comporte la plus grande
population juive et la plus grande
population musulmane évidemment pour
nous c'est un enjeu majeur de rétablir
une question d'équilibre dans l'horreur
c'est triste à dire et de faire en sorte
aussi que d'éviter que cela déborde sur
notre territ on va en parler mais vous
vous parliez de la part de
responsabilité de Benyamine netanahou il
y a des accusations qui pèsent sur
benjamine netanahou qui auraiit joué la
politique du pire en favorisant le Hamas
au détriment de l'Autorité palestinienne
pour éviter de négocier la solution à
deux états est-ce que vous partagez
cette thèse ça ça fait très longtemps
c'était le c'était l'un des bases de
stratégie dont le j'avais parlé de ça
dans un détail dans un autre livre
s'appelé le Prophète et la pandémie on
analysant très préc je lu reviens dans
la figure oui l'ancien patron du du
mossade Yosi Cohen qui passait son temps
à à Doha et qui avait sous ses sous les
l'inspiration netanahou et qui avait
organisé ses transferts d'argent tous
les mois ou un avion de Qatar Airways
arrivit à l'aéroport benouron à Tel Aviv
euh où des valises de de cash en dollar
paril y a pas de le distributeur de
d'argent à Gaza était transféré sous
haute garde du mossat dans des des jeeps
qui devaient rester à Gaza parce que
j'ai l'impression d'avoir reconnu
certaines euh lors du des images du
massacre du 7 octobre jusqu'à la
frontière à à Rafa Herz où là frontière
qui était à l'époque quasiment
infranchissable moi je l'ai franchi
plusieurs fois légalement si vous voulez
quand j'allais rencontrer des gens du
Hamas à Gaza un Hamas qui a beaucoup
changé en au cours des années il faut
bien dire ça aussi à l'époque quand je
je fréquentais ces dirigeants ça n'était
pas complètement le le le produit de
l'Iran il y avait une dimension
nationale qui était très forte et
aujourd'hui l'Iran tient tout et ensuite
les services secrets égyptiens
escortaient les valises et les jeeps
depuis la la barrière de sécurité qui a
été
désactivé d'une façon que qu'on ne peut
pas attribuer simplement un garagiste de
du du Hamas avec sa sa avec sa clé à
molette hein c'est pas possible de
croire ça il faut un état avec une
structure il faut le passe d'Aran
lesgardun la Révolution et contrairement
à ce que racontent les renseignements
américains et donc euh ensuite il il
donnait l'argent au Hamas qui bien sûr
payait les fonctionnaires les hôpitaux
et C et prenait d'importants frais de
dossier comme vous l'imaginez netanahou
a a été dans cette politique si vous
voulez subventionner la cocote minute de
Gaza pour qu'elle n'explose pas
maintenant Gaza juste à la à la surface
de l'eau pour que le et donc d'une
certaine manière c'était sa façon si je
puis dire d'évacuer la question de Gaza
comme la poussière sous le tapis et
pendant ce temps-là on faisait des
accords sous l'égide du président Trump
mais cette cette stratégie
prédatait le président Trump qu'on a
appelé qu'on a appelé le pacte d'Abraham
c'est-à-dire chercher des liens entre
divers gouvernements arabes qui
bénéficiait de la technologie et de
l'armement israélien et et l'État
d'Israël qui mais c'est gouvernement
aujourd'hui dans une position un peu
délicate au Maroc notamment vous parliez
de l'Iran l'Iran qui a appelé hier à
rompre tout lien avec Israël et qui a
appelé au boycott de ses produits l'Iran
veut s'imposer comme le champion de la
cause palestinienne aujourd'hui pas
seulement de la cause palestinienne oui
mais de l'ensemble exercer l'hégémonie
sur le monde arabe si vous voulez depuis
un certain nombre de d'années déjà le la
rivalité entre chiit et sunnit est très
importante notamment depuis la
révolution iranienne 1979 où romainie
s'est imposée comme une sorte de Ch
champion tiermondiste de la cause arabe
palestinien alors qu'il n'est ni arabe
ni sunnite et on a vu au cours des 40 50
dernières années des basculements de
l'égémonie vous voyez quand romainie
fait la fatie du 14 février 1989 contre
Salman rouged il tire le tapis sous les
pieds des sunnites qui viennent de
chasser l'Armée rouge d'Afghanistan le
départ l'Armée Rouge et le lendemain on
ne le voit pas et il il gagne la guerre
médiatique le 11 septembre 2001 c'est la
réponse si j'ose dire du berger sunnite
à la berger archite et c'est Ben Laden
avec l'attaque spectaculaire
sur sur les tours jumelles et sur le
Pentagone qui gagne la guerre médiatique
le 7 octobre 2023 de nouveau c'est un
enjeu de guerre médiatique exceptionnel
puisque c'est une sorte de 11 septembre
pour Israël c'est-à-dire qu'on expose
que Israël invin comme l' l'Amérique
invincible ne sont que des géants des
colosses au pied d'argile pour reprendre
la métaphore biblique et là simplement
c'est un parti sunnite les Frères
musulmans mais les Frères musulmans
n'ont jamais été comme les salafistes
des antiiites primaire au contraire la
révolution islamique en Iran a été
nourri de la lecture des Frères
musulmans et quand la République
islamique a eu le pouvoir ils ont fait
très rapidement émettre un timbre poste
à l'image de
le penseur de l'islamisme radical frère
musulman supplicié par Nasser en Égypte
en 66 vous voyez et donc tout ça ça a
permis aujourd'hui à l'Iran en
instrumentalisant le à l'Iran chiite en
instrumentalisant le Hamas arabe et
sunnit de se d'apparaître c'est ce
qu'ils sont en train de faire comme le
héros aut os de la résistance l' la
résistance et l'un des choses qui le
montre aujourd'hui c'est la visite qui
vient de se produire du ministre iranien
des Affaires étrangères monsieur
abdolahan qui a fait une conférence de
presse commune avec son homologue turc
monsieur FIDAL l'ancien patron du
renseignement et qui ont d'une certaine
manière construit une sorte de front qui
vise à l'hégémonie sur le monde musulman
contre l'Arabie Saoudite il faut bien
voir que l'Arabie Saoudite est visée
directement par ses affaires n'oubliez
pas que l'attentat enfin la la radia
monstrueuse du octobre a lieu juste
après que deux ministres israéliens ont
été reçus en Arabie Saoudite de quoi
avaiit peur les Iraniens que par exemple
les Israéliens fournissent si accord il
y avait s'ils allaient plus loin le dô
de fer par exemple au à l'Arabie
Saoudite permettant d'éviter que les
Routis qui sont aujourd'hui tout à fait
dans l'actualité qui sont totalement
dans la main des Iraniens qui leur
fournissent les armes des missiles et
cetera attaquent le territo aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ce rapprochement re Israël
et certains pays arabes dont l'Arabie
Saoudite qui était en cours il est mort
pour vous avec cette attaque du 7ct il
il est clairement mis comment on dirait
en anglais sur le Back Bur sur le feu de
derrière il est en en position il
mij indéiablement et et de l'Iran et
c'est aussi aujourd'hui pour la Turquie
vous voyez rappelez-vous quand il y
avait la pandémie euh Mohamed Ben Salman
le prince héritier l'homme fort de
d'Arab leader saoudien avait en bon
élève de l'OMS n'avait pas organisé un
pèlerinage avec 3 millions de personnes
puisque les pèlerinages sont propices à
la propagation des pandémies depuis
toute l'histoire et donc il avait mis un
pninage symbolique métonymique avec des
Français musulmans des Égyptiens des
Indonésiens chacun séparé avec les
barrières sanitaires et le masque mais
vous n'aviez pas lesffet d'image vous ne
pouvvez pas montrer sur Public Sénat 3
millions de musulmans sous la houlette
des Saoudiennes qu'a fait Erdogan
pendant son là il a réislamisé
Sainte-Sophie en disant je suis le
descendant du Calif c'est moi le leader
du monde musulman et vous voyez cette
lutte pour l'égémonie vous en avait une
nouvelle occurrence aujourd'hui oui mais
justement alors Erdogan il qualifie le
Hamas de mouvement de libérateur il
accuse l'Occident d'être le principal
coupable des massacre à Gaza quelle
roule joue-t-il aujourd'hui quelle roule
joue la Turquie il va même plus loin
puisque il a considéré que c'était une
guerre de la Croix contre le croissant
que je sache il ne s'agit pas de croire
en l'occurrence mais plutôt d'étoiles de
David mais bon ça lui a échappé et il
considèr effectivement que parce que
notamment les Américains conseillent les
les Israéliens dans l'offensive parce
que il y a aujourd'hui la chose la plus
importante de l'influence militaire
américaine c'est le porte-avion Gérald
Ford je ne sais pas s'il est bien ou mal
nommé mais qui est juste devant
le la frontière maritime entre le
Hezbollah au sud du Liban et l'État
hébreu et si il y avait une offensive
massive du Hezbollah parce que le
Hezbollah dispose au sud du Liban
d'armement beaucoup plus important que
ce qu'à le Hamas dans la mesure où il
approvisionnement terrestre depuis
l'Iran à partir de la travers la Syrie
euh ça serait bien sûr quelque chose qui
prendrait l'armée israélienne à revers
ça ça veut dire que les Américains
déclenchent la foudre et l'Iran
aujourd'hui a déjà gagné d'une certaine
manière suffisamment dans cette affaire
en faisant dérailler le processus de
paix euh il faudra qu'une enquête trouve
les responsabilités exactes dans le
bombardement de l'hôpital el Ahli vous
savez où tout le monde a dit euh ça veut
dire l'Hôpital National non pas Halali
comme le disait la presse française euh
qui euh qui a fait que Biden est arrivé
de son avion il n'a rien pu faire parce
qu'on l' a tout annulé parce qu'on a dit
c'est les israéliens qui ont bombardé il
s'avère c'est le Djihad islamique euh on
ne sait pas s' l'ont fait véritablement
exprès ou non jjihad islamique est une
créature manipulée par l'Iran donc on
voit bien que les Iraniens ont gagné
beaucoup de points pour l'instant est-ce
que ils sont prêts à un affrontement qui
est au bord de l'affrontement nucléaire
je ne le pense pas parce que il
n'auraiit pas le rapport de force ils
ont suffis ils sont pour eux aujourd'hui
le la situ c'est euux qui ont gagné la
première manche indéiablement Gilles
kpel on va parler du climat en France
vous parliez des étoiles de David des
étoiles de David ont été retrouvées
taguées sur des immeubles dans Paris
dans plusieurs ville
d'île-de-fance 857 actes antisémites ont
été recensés dans le pays depuis le 7
octobre dont 60 % dirigé contre des
personnes c'est plus que sur le reste de
l'année est-ce qu'aujourd'hui il y a un
antisémitisme qui ressurgit en France à
l'occasion de ce conflit et est-ce que
vous iriez jusqu'à parler
d'antisémitisme d'atmosphère alors euh
déjà pour le l'affaire
des des éilav des étoiles de David au
pochoir hein donc ça nécessite un peu
d'infrastructure puisqu'il fallait quand
même qu'il a un pochoir il semble
d'après ce que j'ai entendu chez
certains de vos collègues ce matin que
des personnes éent été arrêtées qui sont
not des des étrangers en situation
irrégulière venu d'un pays du centre
sud-est de l'Europe donc attendons
l'enquête oui on va attendre la fin de
l'enquête mais quand même les chiffres
donnés par geréral armanin sont énormes
857 actes antisémites voilà et parce que
si vous voulez après la diffusion des
images du 7 octobre il y a le sentiment
finalement que on peut y aller que c'est
qu' y a une sorte d'impunité et je vois
que euh parmi un certain nombre de
personnes appartenant euh euh à la
population juive française je préfère ne
pas utiliser person le terme de
communauté mais c'est mon choix euh il y
a un sentiment de très grande inquiétude
et euh une inquiétude qui effectivement
quand on quand on voit les les images
qui font qui font froid dans le dos
évidemment euh surtout les images les
plus les plus atroces les plus les plus
gores C qui circule chez les jeunes et
bien sûr pour nous en France c'est un
c'est un enjeu absolument fondamental de
faire passer le message que quels que
soi nos origines nos confessions nos
philosophies ce qui nous rassemble dans
la société française est beaucoup plus
important que ce qui nous divise donc
mais il a entendu aujourd'hui ce message
notamment chez les jeunes puisque vous
en parlez et bien il faut le faire
passer et c'est le pour plutôt que une
vari tion sur mon djihadismeatmosphère
je préférais citer mon très fameux et
éminent collègue Bernard Rougier qui a
parlé d'entrepreneur de colère ce sont
écrit co al re et donc le ceux qui en
ceux qui sont les entrepreneurs de
colère dans cette affaire sont
certainement des gens qui peuvent tomber
aujourd'hui sous le coup de la loi et il
faut bien il faut bien s'en rendre
compte que inciter à la haine des autres
et quelque chose qui est passible de la
loi que celle-ci doit être mise en œuvre
sans sans faiblir et sans faillir sans
quoi le processus devient rapidement
incontrôlable est-ce que ce conflit
Gilles kpel il peut renforcer
l'islamisme en
France bien c'est Cuxa même qui en sont
les promoteurs évidemment s'en réclament
puisque on l'a déjà vu à l'occasion des
attentats commis par daesh et c'est
c'est quel depuis l'affaire de Montauban
rappelez-vous quand Mohamed Mera commet
ses atrocités pendant la campagne
présidentielle qui allait se solder par
la défaite de Nicolas Sarkozi et la
victoire de François Hollande en 2012 il
commence par tuer des soldats euh qui
portent l'uniforme français et dont il
pensent qu'ils sont musulmans certains
l'étaient d'autres étent originair des
Antilles et parce que selon lui ce sont
des apostat de l'islam qui ont trahi
l'islam portant l'univ français qu'il
faut donc exécuter ensuite où va-t-il il
va à Toulouse à l'école auzar Tor et il
tue des enfants juifs comme on a tué des
enfants juifs le 7 octobre et leur
professeurs au nom de sa vision
délirante et extrémiste que que des ce
sont des mécréants et que les mécréant
doivent être mis à mort selon la
conception salafo jjihadiste qui l'a de
la cette religion et qui était inspiré
par Abou mAb souri qui était l'un des
principaux doctrinaires de de daesh qui
avait qui était francophone et qui est
passé une dizaine d'années en Europe
vous vous dites dans votre livre que le
djihadisme il alterne des phases de
force et des phase de faiblesse que là
on était plutôt dans une phase de
faiblesse est-ce que le 7 octobre va
faire basculer le djihadisme dans une
nouvelle phase de force et une nouvelle
séquence du djihadisme mondial alors
indéiablement euh le 7 octobre a été une
ligne de partage des EAU on est on entre
dans une nouvelle phase très clairement
qui met aussi la Palestine au centre du
jeu pour daesh la Palestine était un
enjeu secondaire leur enjeu principal
c'était de faire tomber le régime de
Bachar alAssad de créer un émirat entre
la Syrie et un émirat l'État islamique
comme il appelait Dala en à cheval entre
l'Irak et la Syrie pour créer une sorte
d'état ROG d'État voyou islamiste qui
fasse régner la terreur partout dans le
monde aujourd'hui en remettant l'enjeu
palestinien au centre bien évidemment ça
a un écho beaucoup plus grand dans des
populations musulmanes dans leur
ensemble qui sont pas forcément des
islamistes et qui considère que la
question israelllo-palestinienne
précisément la manière dont ça a été
géré par la communauté internationale
avec les États-Unis à leur tête et
procède d'une injustice et donc les
islamistes s'emparent de cette cause et
veulent se faire les champions de la
cause arabe de la cause musulmane
s'adressant y compris à des populations
qui ne sont pas spontanément islamistes
des arabes qui sont pas particulièrement
salafistes pieux qui peuvent boire de
l'alcool s'il le souhaite mais qui du
coup vont se trouver face à ce choix en
position d'accuser l'Occident de ne pas
d'avoir été injuste on voudrait vous
entendre sur un dernier sujet Gill Capel
c'est la la loi immigration qui va
arriver lundi ici au Sénat les les
républicains font de la régularisation
des travailleurs dans les métiers en
tenstion une ligne rouge ils disent que
cette mesure va créer un appel d'air
est-ce qu'ils ont raison alors ça m'est
difficile de prendre position
publiquement c'est pas mon rôle moi je
suis universitaire et j'essaie de mais
est-ce que ça peut créer un appel d' de
T de telle mesure ben le problème c'est
que les métiers entention il faut bien
que quelqu'un le fasse et euh donc si on
a personne pour travailler si vous
voulez on ne peut pas à la fois avoir
une attitude hédoniste considérant à ne
plus avoir d'enfants les enfants ça
coûte cher et on ne peut pas vivre sa
vie de de beauobo de classe moyenne et
ne pas avoir d'enfants est en déclin
démographique et en même temps
considérer que personne ne peut faire
les travaux que les Français ne
souhaitent plus faire qu'est-ce que
c'est les métiers en ttention c'est les
gens qui
creusent pour remplacer le gaz et ceux
qui préparent la les infrastructures
pour les Jeux Olympiques et cetera et
c'est bien le problème on peut on peut
dire non on veut plus d'immigrés mais en
même temps il faut trouver des solutions
pour que les Français dans ce cas-là
travaillent on peut pas dire que depuis
l'épidémie de covid il y ait un une
excitation au travail extrême chez un
grand nombre de nos compatriotes vous
savez moi je vais vous dire j'habite en
partie à Menton sur la frontière
franco-italienne je vois tous les jours
la situation de de l'appel d'air
migratoire je vu les renforcements des
baraquements dans lesquels on met les
personnes en situation irrégulière que
la police sort du train tous les jours
qu'il renvoie en Italie qui ensuite
repasse par la forêt pour la frontière
et qui vont alimenter directement le
marché des stupéfiants dans le quartier
des moulin à Nice je suis parfaitement
au fait de ces questions un dernier mot
j Gil cal ce projet de loi il veut aussi
faciliter les expulsions mais on sait
que beaucoup de pays ne veulent pas
reprendre leur ressortissant est-ce
qu'il faut que la France durcisse ses
relations avec les pays Arab pour les
contraindre à reprendre leur
ressortissant alors ça a déjà été fait
sans beaucoup de succès notamment avec
le Maroc l'Algérie la Tunisie ça a été
l'un des éléments clés de la crise
franco-marocaine puisque le ministre de
l'Intérieur a pensé que en refusant
massivement des visas à des Marocains
francophiles de classe moyenne pour
contraindre leur état à reprendre des
délinquants marocains ou algérien ou
autres exulz mais c'est au Maroc là cé
la question s'est posée le plus
fermement euh ça du coup ça ça aurait un
effet ça a eu un effet punitif sur des
Marocains francophiles et ça n'a pas eu
véritablement des faits sur le Marzan je
pense qu'il faut négocier ça d'une autre
manière d'après ce que je comprends la
situation est aujourd'hui en voie
d'amélioration notamment parce que le
Maroc qui avait beaucoup misé sur les
relations avec Israël et désigné un peu
la France comme un bou émissaire de
substitution aujourd'hui est en train de
retrouver peut-être une vision plus
équilibrée des ch et il faut s'en
réjouir merci g merci beaucoup d'avoir
été notre invité on remonte votre livre
prophète en son pays c'est aux édition
de l'Observatoire merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous on passe au club des
territoires